[Musique]
quand j'étais petit lorsque nous venions
à saint denis mes parents m'emmenaient
toujours au jardin de l'état
mais là lorsque je regarde la ville de
saint denis
je vois un des milieux les plus modifié
par l'homme mais si je me tourne vers
les eaux
on a encore des milieux intacte et sans
doute qui arrivait jusqu'au niveau de
l'océan et je pense à ces navigateurs
qui lorsqu'ils ont découvert l'île ont
découvert un éden avec une végétation
luxuriante de très nombreuses oiseaux
qui vivaient dans les forêts des
poissons à foison dans les rivières et
l'homme s'installe et pour cela il est
obligé de défricher défricher pour ces
habitations défricher pour mettre en
place des cultures pour nourrir les
habitants
et c'est ainsi que petit à petit tout le
pourtour de l'île sur le littoral a été
modifié et même jusque dans les ca qu
aujourd'hui il reste à peu près 30% de
cette végétation encore à peu près
intact et ses 30% ont été inscrits au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité
il appartient donc aux réunionnais de
transmettre aux générations futures
cette végétation ce bien qui est unique
parce que il contient des espèces qui
n'existe nulle part ailleurs qu'à l'île
de la réunion
si on me demande aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui est le plus important pour demain
c'est de trouver un équilibre entre un
développement nécessaire de notre île
mais une non indispensables préservation
de la nature et c'est un nous
réunionnais
de trouver cette balance